in 2007 all these were replaced with one
portable object but on paper iPhone
wasn't all that revolutionary without 3G
an app store or expandable memory some
argued whether it should even be
considered a smartphone it also wasn't
the first of its kind blackberry curve
was cheaper and more capable so why was
iPhone so successful other smartphones
like the BlackBerry or unintuitive if
you needed one for business you'd learn
how to use it but the design wasn't
compelling enough for the average user
the secret feature of the iPhone was
called skeuomorphism apps looked and
worked like their physical counterparts
so anyone can pick up an iPhone and feel
at home the news app looked like a
newsstand and Game Center looked as a
casino would no need to learn iPhone
iPhone learned you now that people have
adapted to touchscreen mobile computers
user interfaces are moving on Windows 8
iOS 7 and other platforms have switched
to a flat design but skeuomorphism
wasn't a design fad it's a tool which
will be used again with unfamiliar
technology new products often try to be
as forward-thinking and futuristic as
possible but this ignores an important
lesson of the past design is a language
you may want to invent a more efficient
language but you can't expect people to
learn it the best design uses language
people are familiar with because it
isn't flashy technology that changes the
world
it's the accessible kind